¿Sabíais que el CEO de Google, Sundar Pichai,
nació en la India? ¡Pero esperad un momento!
Porque el CEO de Microsoft, Satya Nadella
TAMBIÉN es de la India. Y a que no adivináis
dónde nació el CEO de Adobe, Santanu Narayen
¡Exacto! También es de la India. Vamos a
decirlo claro, India está conquistando Silicon
Valley.
En realidad, podemos decir que India está
conquistando la industria del software en
todo el mundo. Por ejemplo ¿Cuál es la empresa
de servicios de tecnología más grande del
mundo? Alguno pensará en Accenture o alguna
parecida ¿Verdad? ¡Error! ¡Craso error!
La respuesta correcta es Tata Computing Services.
Y sí, TAMBIÉN son de la India.
Y ya sé lo que estaréis pensando ahora…
¿La India? ¿Pero no son un país pobre?
Pues sí, tenéis razón. Dos tercios de los
Indios viven por debajo de la línea de pobreza.
73 millones de Indios están en la pobreza
extrema. 68 millones viven en chavolas. Y
sólo el 8% tiene un título universitario
en comparación con el 34% de Estados Unidos.
De hecho, el 25% de los Indios son analfabetos.
Pero la realidad es que hay dos Indias totalmente
distintas. Por un lado tenemos la India normal:
la pobre. Pero dentro de esa India hay otra
India, que es podríamos llamar la Tekindia,
es decir, la India tecnológica. Si TECIndia
fuera un país independiente, sería tan rico
como Alemania. Tendría un PIB de 177.000
millones de dólares y una población de 4
millones de personas, que son los empleados
en este sector. Tan solo 4 empresas: TCS,
Infosys, HCL y Wipro tienen una plantilla
de más de un millón de personas. Y sí,
estas cuatro empresas son Indias.
A estas alturas, supongo que tendréis un
montón de preguntas ¿Cómo un país tan
pobre ha podido desarrollar una industria
tan compleja como el software? Como un país
con una tasa de analfabetismo tan alta ha
podido convertirse en el segundo mayor exportador
de software del mundo? Hoy vamos a responder
a estas preguntas pero antes, vamos a ver
un poco de historia.
EL CAMINO EQUIVOCADO
Cuando pensamos en la política India, pensamos
en Mahatma Gandhi. Pero en realidad, ESE Gandhi
fue asesinado en 1948. En realidad, una de
las figuras más importantes de nuestra historia
no es Ghandi, o al menos, no ESE Gandhi…
sino JAWARLAHAL NEHRU. Este señor fue el
primer Primer Ministro de India. Bajo su gobierno,
India aprobó su constitución y se convirtió
en un país independiente. Ya en los años
50, Nehru tenía una visión muy clara para
su país: quería convertirlo en el líder
en fabricación de ordenadores. Pensadlo bien:
eran los años 50, la revolución de los ordenadores
estaba empezando. Todavía había una oportunidad
para que un país nuevo compitiera con Occidente.
La pregunta es ¿Cómo se hace eso?
En lugar de seguir el modelo británico, Nehru
decidió imitar la política de Stalin ¡Ojo!
Esto no significa que India se convirtiera
en un país comunista. Pero sí tomaron muchos
elementos de la Unión Soviética. Especialmente
dos: los planes quinquenales y la prohibición
de importaciones. India quería proteger a
sus empresas locales. Así es como surgieron
grandes gigantes nacionales como TATA. ¡Sí,
hablamos del mismo TATA que fabrica coches!
También crearon las primeras aerolíneas
de la India y una empresa de ordenadores:
Tata Computing Services.
A la vez, el Gobierno decidió apostar por
la educación superior. En los años 60, India
construyó montones de los llamados Institutos
Indios de Tecnología. De repente, cientos
de Indios estaban preparados para trabajar
en esa nueva industria de los ordenadores
¿El problema? El problema es que… ¡No
había empresas para contratarles!
Con la excepción de Tata, apenas había empresas
para contratarles. Como habían prohibido
las exportaciones de tecnología, ninguna
fábrica podía comprar los materiales necesarios
para hacer ordenadores. Para que os hagáis
una idea, en 1970, India tenía únicamente
150 ordenadores ¡En todo el país! Y esos
ordenadores estaban importados por IBM, que
había logrado sortear un sinfín de regulaciones.
En ese momento es cuando aparece la segunda
protagonista de nuestra historia: GANDHI.
Pero no, no hablamos de ESE Gandhi… ¡Sino
de INDIRA Gandhi! Fue la Primera Ministra
de India durante los años 60 y 70. Y no,
esta Gandhi no tenía nada que ver con Mahatma.
En realidad, Indira Gandhi era la hija del
primer protagonista de nuestra historia, el
señor NEHRU. Pues bien, Indira Gandhi se
dio cuenta de que había 150 ordenadores que
habían cruzado la frontera ¿Y qué creéis
que hizo? ´”Oh Dios Mío! Alguien está
comprando ordenadores extranjeros! ¡Qué
escándalo! ¡Eso significa que no estamos
regulando lo suficiente!” Así es como en
1978, India sacó una nueva ley que hacía
que importar ordenadores fuera casi imposible.
Obviamente IBM se marchó de India pocos meses
después de que se aprobara esa ley.
Y diréis ¡Esto sería un buen momento para
las empresas locales! ¿Verdad? Pues no. Para
nada. Esa ventana de oportunidad se terminó
de cerrar en ese momento. La posible industria
tecnológica India desapareció en ese momento…
mientras el resto del mundo estaba demasiado
ocupado comprando ordenadores Japoneses y
Estadounidenses.
Sin embargo, todo cambió en 1982. Ahora mismo
lo vamos a ver.
APRENDIENDO DE LOS ERRORES
El año 1982 será recordado en la India como
el año en el que se celebraron los Juegos
Asiáticos: algo así como los Juegos Olímpicos
pero sólo para Asia. Y el organizador de
esos juegos era, nada más y nada menos que…
Gandhi! Pero no el Gandhi que conocéis…
ni la que acabáis de conocer. En este caso
hablamos de RAJIV Gandhi. De nuevo, no tenía
ningún parentesco con Mahatma Gandhi… pero
era el hijo de Indira Gandhi. (Se ve que en
la India se toman muy en serio eso de la “familia
política”)
Sin embargo, este Gandhi era totalmente distinto
de su madre. Gandhi Junior era un amante de
la tecnología y quería usar los ordenadores
para sus Juegos Asiáticos: para programar
las distintas competiciones, para registrar
los resultados, los anuncios, etc… Y ahí
es cuando se dio cuenta de la realidad: ¡Apenas
había ordenadores en todo el país!
Esto fue toda una epifanía para él. Así
que, tan pronto como llegó a Primer Ministro,
dio un giro de 180º a la política del país.
Tan pronto como llegó a Primer Ministro,
quitó todas los aranceles y prohibiciones
a la importación de ordenadores. De un día
para otro, los Indios podían comprar PCs
siempre y cuando los usaran para desarrollar
software. Gandhi se había dado cuenta de
una cosa: ya era muy tarde para que la India
compitiera fabricando hardware. Pero en este
momento había una nueva ventana de oportunidad:
una nueva revolución que estaba empezando:
la revolución del software ¡Y vaya si dio
resultado!
¿Harto de pagar una fortuna a tus programadores
en Estados Unidos? ¡Bienvenido a… TECIndia!
¡Universidades de lujo! ¡Trabajadores cualificados!
¡Y todo eso por menos del 20% de un sueldo
en los U-S-A! ¡Todo eso y más en… TECIndia!
Tenemos 0 aranceles a los ordenadores. Ni
siquiera necesitas asociarte con un partner
local para establecerte aquí. Incluso tenemos
nuestro propio satélite para que todas tus
oficina en California se comunique con…
TECIndia!
(Exenciones fiscales disponibles. Consulte
a su contable Indio para más información)
¡Unete a la revolución… TECIndia! Compaq
ya lo ha hecho. También Texas Instruments.
Incluso IBM ha regresado al país ¡Todos
ahorran costes en… TECIndia! Llama ahora
al teléfono que aparece en pantalla.
De repente, India pasó de tener menos de
1000 ordenadores en 1978 a más de 80,000
en 1990. Empresas como Tata Computer Services
o Hindustan Computers trabajaban en casi todos
los procesos de gigantes como Hewlett Packard.
Y el gobierno estaba encantado. Antes que
muchos países occidentales, ellos estaban
siendo pioneros en cosas como máquinas de
voto electrónico, banca electrónica o incluso
venta de billetes electrónica. De repente,
el mundo entero miraba a la India como el
lugar donde encontrar programadores.
La revolución de los ordenadores llega a
India… más o menos
Por estas fechas es cuando nace la Asociación
Nacional de Empresas de Software y Servicios:
la patronal de TECIndia. Esta empresa se ha
convertido en un lobby importantísimo en
India. Y ha sido fundamental en la liberalización
de la tecnología en este país.
Pero vale, ya sé lo que me estará pensando
alguno: ¡Fonseca, cómo se te ve el plumero!
¿De verdad nos vas a decir que todo ha sido
tan sencillo? Liberalizan un sector y ¡Boom!
Todos felices. Pues no, tenéis razón. Hay
una pequeña trampa en esta historia.
¿Os acordáis de todos esos recién graduados
que sabían mucho de informática pero no
tenían empresas donde trabajar? Pues muchos
de ellos se fueron a Silicon Valley. Con el
tiempo, fueron ascendiendo en sus empresas
hasta tener una influencia real. Pues bien,
estos IndoAmericanos fueron los que ayudaron
al Gobierno Indio a diseñar una legislación
a la medida de las empresas tecnológicas.
Y también convencieron a los directivos estadounidenses
de que abrieran oficinas en… TECIndia. Esto
explica, por ejemplo, por qué India construyó
esos satélites para que las oficinas Inglesas
y Estadounidenses se comunicaran con la India.
A ningún político que no trbajara en software
se le ocurriría esta idea.
Y así es como se creó todo un círculo virtuoso
para la tecnología en la India. Incluso la
crisis financiera de los años 90, con la
mega devaluación de la rupia incluída, sirvió
para consolidar aún más el poder de TECIndia.
Sí, el resto del país sufría una inflación
galopante. Pero las empresas de software eran
más competitivas debido al cambio de divisa.
Para que os hagáis una idea, en el año 2000,
la industria de software India valía más
de 5000 millones de dólares ¡Pero esperad
un momento! Porque todavía no hemos llegado
al auténtico punto de inflexión de nuestra
historia. El momento en el que TECIndia se
convirtió en al líder global del software.
Ahora mismo lo vamos a ver.
EL EFECTO 2000
Si tenéis más de 30 años, seguro que os
acordaréis bien de lo que digo… ¿Os acordáis
del efecto 2000? En el año 1999, muchos pensaban
que el cambio de siglo traería el fin del
mundo ¡Y lo decían de forma no irónica!
Un panel del sanado describe el Y2K o Efecto
2000 como una crisis mundial. Uno de los eventos
más potencialmente devastadores que América
se haya encontrado nunca.
Veréis, los primeros ordenadores no tenían
discos duros grandes. Así que los informáticos
usaban sólo los dos últimos dígitos del
año para representar el año. Por ejemplo,
en lugar de poner 1960, ponían 60. Eso significa
que 00 podía representar 1900 o 2000. Es
decir, que en el momento en el que el calendario
marcara 1 de enero de… 00 ¡Todos los sistemas
informáticos del mundo entero colapsarían!
Y diréis ¿Qué tiene que ver todo esto con
la India?
Pues, como os dijimos al principio, India
no empezó a tener ordenadores hasta los años
80. Es decir, que todos sus sistemas ya contaban
con equipos más modernos que no tenían ese
problema de los dos dígitos. Es decir, que
mientras el mundo desarrollado podría estar
impactado, la India estaba libre de efecto
2000. Eso les dio una ventaja temporal para
poder ayudar a todos los sistemas informáticos
del mundo a solucionar el efecto 2000. Podemos
decir que TECIndia salvó el mundo. Y ganó
una auténtica fortuna con ello.
Boom en India por la amenaza del Efecto 2000
¿Pero cómo ocurrió todo esto? Hay varios
factores. Primero, India estaba produciendo
100.000 nuevos graduados en informática cada
año. El sueldo de un programador Indio era
un sexto de lo que cobraba su homólogo en
Estados Unidos. Además, TECIndia estaba más
que lista para mandar todos los comerciales
que hicieran falta a los países desarrollados
¿Os acordáis de NASSCOM, la patronal de
TECIndia? Pues se pasearon por todas las ferias
comerciales de Luxemburgo, Oslo, Londres,
Nueva York y San José. Para que os hagáis
una idea, sólo en el año 1998, el Efecto
2000 supuso el 40% de los ingresos de… TECIndia.
Para entonces, India ya se había convertido
en la referencia del software.
Durante la siguiente década, los servicios
de IT se han expandido hasta cubrir los procesos
más complejos: arquitectura de software,
I+D y Business integration. Prácticamente
no hay una empresa de informática que no
tenga una oficina grande en la India.
Y en la última década, TECIndia ha sumado
más de 10.000 empresas nuevas y 2 millones
de trabajadores más ¡Pero esperad un momento!
Porque aquí es donde termina la parte bonita.
Ahora vamos a ver la cara más oscura de TECIndia.
Atentos.
DOS PAÍSES OPUESTOS
Si hay una cosa mala por la que India es famosa
es por su sistema de CASTAS. Como sabéis,
la clase en la que uno nace es muy importante
en este país. Y TECIndia es la mejor muestra:
un país rico dentro de uno pobre. La pregunta
es… ¿Qué pasa con la otra India? Pues,
por sorprendente que parezca, sólo el 10%
de la población tiene acceso a Internet.
En las zonas rurales, este número baja hasta
el 3%.
Por supuesto que trabajar en TECIndia es un
lujo. Un programador normal puede ganar un
sueldo de unos 10.000 dólares al año. Puede
parecer una miseria. Pero pensad que esto
sigue siendo la India. Según EXPATISTAN.COM,
si vivís en una ciudad como Bangalore, podéis
alquilar un piso por menos de 200 dólares
al mes. Así que sí, los informáticos en
la India viven bien. Sólo el llamado corredor
de Bangalore tiene 67.000 empresas. Eso incluye
gigantes Indios como Infosys, Mindtree o Wipro.
Pero entrar en TECIndia requiere un nivel
educativo muy alto, inglés fluído y un capital
social inimaginable para la mayor parte de
los Indios.
Ser informático es el auténtico sueño Indio.
No sólo se trata de conseguir un buen trabajo
en Bangalore. También es un pasaje de avión
para poder trabajar en el extranjero. El mundo
entero está deseando contratar Indios.
Japán está desesperado por los teckies Indios…
¿Morderán el anzuelo?
El visado alemán fracasa a la hora de tengar
a los expertos en IT Indios
En Silicon Valley, el 50% de los trabajadores
inmigrantes, esos que toman la famosa Visa
H1B, son Indios. Lo mismo ocurre en Seattle,
donde Amazon y Microsoft tienen sus oficinas
centrales. Pero incluso ahí se mantiene el
sistema de castas. Según Equality Labs, las
multinacionales estadounidenses como Facebook,
Amazon o Microsoft están discriminando a
los Indios de las castas más bajas.
Sin embargo, a pesar de eso, el sueño de
cualquier Indio es entrar en TECIndia.
“Mi ticket de salida”: La aldea India
donde toda familia tiene un ingeniero
Por ejemplo, en una aldea que se llama PATWA
TOLI, en el Norte de la India, la comunidad
se llegó a organizar para dar ayudas a los
niños para que pudieran estudiar en esas
Universidades tecnológicas. Los padres invierten
los ahorros de toda una vida, incluso piden
créditos en el banco para pagar un coach
que ayude a los niños a pasar los exámenes
de ingreso. Sólo en 2017, 20 chicos de esta
aldea fueron aceptados en una de estas universidades.
Pero a pesar de estos esfuerzos, las castas
más pobres suponen tan sólo el 9% de todos
los estudiantes.
¿Y qué pasa con el resto de la India? ¿Por
qué no crecen tanto como TECIndia? Lo cierto
es que, fuera de los ordenadores, India es
uno de los países más proteccionistas que
existen. Eso y el paraíso de la burocracia.
Según el Índice de Facilidad para Hacer
Negocios, India está junto a Arabia Saudita
o Ucrania.
Por ejemplo, cada producto tiene un impuesto
distinto. A veces, incluso distintos modelos
del mismo producto tienen un IVA distinto.
Hay barreras al mercado incluso dentro del
propio país. Por ejemplo, si quieres pasar
de un estado a otro, encontrarás largas colas
de camiones ¿Por qué? ¡Porque están esperando
a pasar la aduana! Y cada vez que pasan a
otro estado dentro del mismo país… ¡Otra
vez a pasar la aduana!
¿Y qué pasa con los aranceles? Sí, los
ordenadores se pueden importar sin problemas.
No podemos decir lo mismo del resto de productos:
desde medicinas hasta ropa. India tiene unos
de los aranceles más altos del mundo. Y si
alguien se esperaba que el Gobierno de extrema
derecha de Narendra Modi iba a cambiarlo…
¡Podéis seguir esperando!
India planea poner aranceles extra y barreras
de Mercado a 300 productos de importación
En los últimos dos años, Amazon y Wall-Mart
se han convertido en el objetivo de la furia
de Narendra Modi. Al igual que Gandhi hizo
todo lo posible por echar a IBM del país,
Modi parece obsesionado con hacer lo mismo
con Amazon. Incluso hay un debate serio en
este país para prohibir a este ecommerce
para operar en todo el país. Y, en el momento
en el que hacemos este vídeo, esto es lo
que está ocurriendo en India.
La Confederación de Comerciantes de India
quiere una prohibición de 7 días para Amazon
por violar la regla del país de origen
Así que ahora la pregunta es… ¿Por qué
la India no extiende las reglas de TECHIndia
al resto del país? ¿O tal vez el éxito
de TECIndia es sólo una burbuja que terminará
estallando? Podéis dejarme vuestra respuesta
en los comentarios.
Mientras tanto, no olvidéis que aquí, en
VisualPolitik, sacamos vídeos nuevos todas
las semanas. Así que suscribíos a este canal
y dadle a la campanita para no perderos ninguna
de nuestras actualizaciones. Si os ha gustado
este vídeo, dadle a LIKE y nos vemos en el
próximo. Un abrazo y hasta pronto.